[موسيقى]
والله يوم
1711 سكان الشمال واجينا عند دار قرايبنا
دار عوض
كلنا كنت على الباب بشحن في
البطاريه صوب ضرم علينا صاروخ زنانه صوبنا
ثلاثه وطلعنا ودونا على كمال
عدوان اول ما وصلنا كمال عدوان بعديه يمكن
بع دقائق نزلوا الدار كلها ست طوابق راح
فيها 70 شهيد ونجي من الدار هذك اللي
طلعوا كانوا متصاوب
اجينا هنا عن سيبنا من دار
غيس بعد 41 يوم في تاريخ
28/12 نزلوا الدار كلها في الدار
هذك في
55 مراه مع طفل
صغير هذول اللي استشهدوا غير كبار السن
يمكن كل الشباب اللي كانوا فيها يمكن سبع
ثمان تنفار والباقي كله نساء
واطفال وفي هذه الدار لما ضربوها 3
نفر منهم 17 نساء
واطفال وهي اللي صار احنا ربنا كتبلنا عمر
جديد الحمد
لله انا استشهد لي في الدار هديك امي
ومرتي وثلاثه بنتين وابني الصغير ضل لي
ولد كان قبلها بيوم الصوب كان رايح يعبي
مي وتحول على الجنوب ايام ما دخلوا على
الاندونيسي طلع بالصليب الاحمر لما حصل
الاندونيسي هو اللي ضل لي كان ضايل ابوي
بس في الدار هذه استشهد ابوي فيها كل
حياتنا انسرقت منه اغلى الناس الحبايب
كلهم
را ضلش
حد حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل مالكم
قبل ما يقصف الدار بنص ساعه تقريبا هت
الدار
قديفه ما قدرناش نطلع كانت الدبابه اخره
الشارع ح واي حد ب يطلع جربنا نطلع كان
نطخ
عليه طلعنا قعدنا شويه فوق كنت قاعد عند
امي طلعت وسبتها طلعت فوق على الطابق اللي
فوق كان معي
ابوي اولاد
عمي كان ابوي مغطي وجه بعد ما قعدنا
تقريبا بخمس دقايق صارت لهوا مادا ما
حسيتش
[موسيقى]
بشي اناس تخلص الحار ح
اب في خواتي وامي تحت برضو بينات بس مش
عارف ايش كيف اطلعهم لازم معدات العمدان
طبقين على ابوي صور لهم يهم كيف العمدان
طبقين